[Music]
rory suspects that teachers in his
school district have less than five
years of experience on average he
decides to test his null hypothesis is
that the mean number of
years of experience is five years and
his alternative hypothesis is that the
true mean years of experience is less
than 5 years using a sample of 25
teachers his sample mean was 4 years and
his sample standard deviation was 2
years
rory wants to use these sample data to
conduct a t-test on the mean assume that
all conditions for inference have been
met
calculate the test statistic for rory's
test so i always just like to remind
ourselves what's going on so you have
your null hypothesis here that the mean
number of years of experience for
teachers in the district is five and
then the alternative hypothesis is that
the mean years of experience is less
than five for teachers in the district
so if this represents all the teachers
in the district the population
then what he did is he took a sample and
said he used a sample of 25 teachers so
n here is equal to 25 and then from that
sample he was able to calculate some
statistics he was able to calculate the
sample mean that sample mean was four
years the sample mean was four years and
then he was also able to calculate the
sample standard deviation the sample
standard deviation was
equal to two years now the whole point
that we do or the main thing we do when
we do significance tests is we say all
right if we assume the null hypothesis
is true
what's the probability of getting
getting a sample mean this low or lower
and if that probability is below a
preset significance level then we reject
the null hypothesis and it suggests the
alternative
but in order to figure out that
probability we need to figure out a test
a test statistic sometimes we use a
z-test if we're using if we're dealing
with proportions but when we deal with
means we tend to use a t-test and the
reason why is if you wanted to figure
out a z-statistic what you would do is
you would take your sample mean
subtract from that the assumed mean from
the null hypothesis so mu and i'll just
put a little zero sub zero there so this
is the assumed mean from the null
hypothesis
and then you would want to
divide
by the standard deviation of the
sampling distribution of the sample mean
so you'd want to divide by that
but this we don't know and so that's why
instead we do a t statistic
in which case we take the difference
between our sample mean and our assumed
population mean the population parameter
and we try to estimate this and we
estimate that with our sample standard
deviation divided by the square root of
our sample size and so if you're
inspired i encourage you even if you're
not inspired i encourage you to pause
this video and try to calculate this t
statistic
well this is going to be equal to let's
see our sample mean is 4 minus our
assumed mean is
5 our assumed population mean is 5. our
sample standard deviation is 2 all of
that over the square root of the sample
size all of that over square root of 25
so this is going to be equal our
numerator is negative 1 so it's negative
1 divided by 2 over 5 which is equal to
negative 1 times 5
over 2 and so this is going to be equal
to equal to
negative 5 over 2 or negative
2.5
and then what we would do in this what
rory would do is then look this t value
up on a t table
and say so if you look at a distribution
of a t statistic something like that and
say okay
we are negative 2.5 below the mean
so negative
negative 2.5 and so what he would want
to do is figure out this area here
because this would be the probability of
being that far below the mean or even
further below the mean and so that would
give us our p-value and then if that
p-value is below some preset
significance level that rory should have
set maybe five percent or one percent
then he'll reject the null hypothesis
which would suggest his suspicion that
the true mean of years of experience for
the teachers in this district is less
than five now another really important
thing to keep in mind is they told us
that assume all conditions for inference
have been met and so that's the assuming
that this was truly a random sample
that each the individual observations
are either truly uh independent or
roughly independent that maybe he
observed either with replacement or it's
less than 10 of the population and he
feels good that the sampling
distribution is going to be roughly
normal and we've talked about that in
other videos